my name is Marlene lushly and I'm 48
years old a reason why I'm here is due
to the riots because of the flyer and I
couldn't get back in to my house really
it was the explosion really that's all
really scared me where i had to wake up
my partner because he was sleeping and
he used his total to get out of
screaming and shine is quite a lot of
what's going on so i don't know we just
we just got out really just so we could
see the fire but from the back way from
where I'm you could actually see where
the house was burning a lot of people
screaming and then we was told by the
police and the fire brigade that and
couldn't go back in so we had to end up
sleeping in the car
day after a man from the council
approached us and said that I do when we
can get a few things out of the house we
grabbed a few fields and when I mean a
few things it was as few things and then
he said that would be able to come back
in four days and they brought it in this
hotel gilroy hotel and we're there ever
since can't get back in don't know when
I can get back in don't know what this
what everything's like in the place I
mean if the electricity's been off all
my food spoil it does steph estate in
really i can't see us going back in
there anytime soon because they've given
him they giving us an offer but it
wasn't suitable because i've got
sciatica arthritis and the stairs it's
just too much for me now they just said
like to stay here and there will get in
contact with me to find another
accommodation so I'm hoping that's going
to be soon because really I'm dismissing
being around my own surrounding with all
my own stuff you know obviously you have
to have a hot meal so I'll go to the
church and I get hot meal I that's been
like for me for the whole of this week
I've been going and getting the hot meal
which is I so appreciate
you go in there they so welcoming thank
you very much the first thing she says
to know what you want for lunch in fact
she's been saying to me like think of
something that you haven't had for a
long time and they and they do it before
you and I think that's so nice and then
when you go in night there's its food
there's clothes that's everything today
and you can just pick what you want you
know I mean and you just feel like oh
something there is someone out there
that does care you know mean it how you
live in your life and like that everyday
things like I said if you go there at
least you know you can get them things
you know like choose clothes film you
know
they won't let us go back in there they
said that they don't think it's table so
they don't want to risk us going back in
there I'm hoping that maybe we can go in
there so I can see you know what kind of
damage is there you know mean and
triangles build our life back again
really